[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pour un look américain jean 1 le lion
c'est le lion donc tout est d'ailleurs
fait un bon run et les étals on a pris
notre mal en patience mais maintenant
vous voyez comment ça fait pas on a
gagné le match avec toulon tout le
québec a bloqué derrière les lions
cette administration côté de la nation
camerounaise vraiment
que dieu continue à nous
launay de cette opportunité
enfin nous faire savoir avait interpellé
et l'amour me manque ma peau qualifié
cette du toit j'ai moi même plus des
liens avec en bouquet lettre contient
certains nous sommes tous derrière
et agile et les patrons
n'accaparent
nous